Thank You congressman Neil I'm the
business of weather I've been here two
or three times or four times before it's
a bit of an embarrassment my long-term
memory not being what it used to be
anyway I know I've been here before on
on quite different issues I wanted to
talk about space in a broad context I'm
gonna try to not spend a whole lot of
time in formal although slightly
off-the-cuff remarks because I'd I'd
love to have a real dialogue as
congressman Neil said space covers a lot
of ground and when we talk about you
know sometimes asked our ask the
question are you for space or are you
against it that's too broad an issue and
it has to be broken down into into
smaller pieces and let me try to
indicate some of the aspects of the
space program that I think everyone
agrees are are cost-effective and should
continue and then let's get into some of
the more difficult and controversial
issues as well excuse me
communication satellites link-up the
planet island nation like Indonesia with
hundreds of separate islands cost of
laying submarine cable prohibitive now
they all can talk to each other via
geostationary satellite business and the
stock market and governments are linked
up the planet is integrated the economic
consequences of communication satellites
are enormous and this is a consequence
of the space program weather satellites
save billions of dollars a year in the
United States alone in
advanced warning about storms and cold
spells that may endanger crops
satellites that are involved with the
military reconnaissance and treaty
verification are as Lyndon Johnson once
said worth their weight in gold because
they calm the paranoids and hotheads on
all sides you don't have to assume the
worst case you can actually see what the
potential adversary is planning and you
can make sure that arms control treaties
are abided by they're extremely
important and should be encouraged this
is not that's not just that's not NASA
obviously that's on the National
Reconnaissance Office DoD CIA and of
things but that is something well worth
supporting satellites that monitor the
environmental health of the earth NASA
calls it mission to Planet Earth is just
in its earliest stages and without going
into the question of the correct
logistics a few large and expensive
satellites many small and and quick
satellites that question apart this is
really vital because through depletion
of the ozone layer through global
warming through runoff of topsoil and in
many other ways the environment that
supports our species is in danger and
it's most important to know what's
happening with a global perspective and
you can only get that from from orbital
altitude
then there are satellites robot
satellites that look out that for
example examine the decaying fires from
the Big Bang the event that began the
universe or at least its most recent
incarnation about 15 billion years ago
the study of distant stars and galaxies
approaches that help us to answer
questions about where this universe came
from and where it's going what its
nature may be every human culture one
way or another has tried to understand
that here we are at the first time in
history when we really have the means of
finding out I think you have to be made
of wood not to be at least a little bit
interested in it and here comparatively
inexpensive robotic spacecraft have made
and are continuing to make enormous
strides spacecraft that directly
investigate through flybys orbiters and
Landers the other worlds in our solar
system an important outlet for
exploration we are an exploratory
species an important way of pumping
fundamental science and something very
important for calibrating our planet by
comparing it with others just just to
give a couple of examples for those
people who think that global warming is
some hoax
invented by liberal college professors
venus is a very useful cautionary tale
here is the nearest planet to the earth
upon it in many respects most like the
earth which has a surface temperature of
900 Fahrenheit hot enough to melt tin or
lead and we know from spacecraft
exploration but the reason for these
hellish temperatures is the massive
carbon dioxide and water vapor
atmosphere on Venus now I'm not
suggesting that there was once a speech
ease of careless venusian x' who
insisted on driving fuel-inefficient
automobiles that's that's not my point
but if you doubt that massive quantities
of carbon dioxide can produce a an
absolutely unlivable environment just
take a look at Venus and likewise with
Viking one of the things we were most
surprised by was to find not only that
there were no microbes on the surface
life might never have arisen on Mars but
that you couldn't even find any organic
molecules molecules built on carbon when
meteorites rich in organic molecules we
know are falling on Mars and and
surviving and the understanding is that
this is cause this is the general
understanding the planetary community by
the fact that Mars has what we might
describe as a planet-wide
ozone hole that is there's no ozone in
the atmosphere
searing ultraviolet light from the Sun
strikes the surface unimpeded and
directly and through its radiation
products like peroxides the ultraviolet
light wipes out organic molecules
isn't this something we ought to pay
attention to we who are busily depleting
our own protective ozone layer other
planets provide I've given you two
examples but there are many others
cautionary tales about what dumb thing
is not to do with the earth and also
about alternative fates of earth-like
worlds and they are extremely important
it seems to me although I confess a
parochial professional interest in this
end of what NASA does and does so ably
now we come to the most difficult issue
and that is manned manned and woman
spaceflight I wish there was a better
word for a while I was toying with crude
CR vwe D but that lent itself to all
sorts of other misunderstand
and so I'll try to say you know human
but if I occasionally slip and same and
I want to stress that I'm fully aware
that there are many important astronauts
who happen to be of the female
persuasion the Apollo program is the
crux of manned human spaceflight and
absolutely cannot be understood except
in the context of the Cold War Apollo is
a creature was a creature of the Cold
War the nation that could orbit lots of
human beings the nation that could sit
down on a predetermined trajectory on a
small spot on the moon the nation that
could send humans to the moon and bring
them safely back to earth was a nation
that had demonstrated its rocket potency
and that's important because it was
rockets that carried strategic weapons
halfway around the earth the United
States and the Soviet Union were busy in
a symbolic mutual intimidation with
other nations potential allies potential
defectors from allies being the
interested bystanders and in this race
the United States says all the world
knows one with Apollo 11 the deal that
President Kennedy made with his science
advisor Jerome weasoner
was that provided Kennedy didn't
describe the Apollo mission as having
anything to do with science he Wiesner
would support it and with a couple of
accidental slips that was that was
abided by the clear demonstration that
Apollo was nothing about science is the
fact that the last astronaut to land on
the moon was the first scientist to land
on the moon soon as the scientists got
there it was clearly a waste of time
well not only did the United States win
the race to put people on the moon but
the Cold War is over the Soviet Union
has collapsed the competitive argument
whatever virtue it may once have had
Sputnik and Yuri Gagarin certainly
scared the United States
whatever Meredith may once have had has
now gone and we have to ask what exactly
is the function of human spaceflight and
because human spaceflight is so
expensive
comparatively this is it seems to me an
essential topic which has to be debated
I don't want to suggest that I know what
the answer is at the end of this debate
but it's a debate which has to be
engaged in and it seems to me the
argument arguments like well we've
always done it
or if we phase out some aspect of manned
spaceflight there'll be jobs lost
these are inadequate arguments if we
cannot justify it on its own merits then
there are many other crying national
needs that are properly
knocking at the door now the mood of the
country is very clear in the in the
middle 80s I thought that a joint us
Soviet human mission to Mars was a good
idea for political reasons to give these
two adversaries that had accumulated
between them some 55,000 nuclear weapons
some common long term high technology
worthy far-seeing
inspiring goal that seemed to me to be a
a real justification and there was a
little window when
scientists seem to have convinced the
Soviet leadership mikhail gorbachev
proposed such a joint mission to the
american leadership
but president reagan turned him down
flat and now the moment has passed and
with the collapse of the soviet union a
substantial part maybe not all of the
justification has passed there is no
question that human expedition
tomorrow's would return enormous ly good
science but the case is certainly not
made that you couldn't return as much or
even more science with the sophisticated
robotic explorers if some amounts of
money more than what we are now spending
on robotics were authorized
there is a spin-off argument which in
the Apollo days when something like this
give us twenty five billion dollars to
send people to the moon and we'll throw
in a free stick list frying-pan
but everybody understands if stick was
frying pans were high on the national
agenda that we could authorize some
money directly aimed that stick was
frying pans and don't have to go to the
moon in order to accomplish it and we
could see in the fading days of Star
Wars some similar desperate arguments
when it was suggested that a hydrogen
bomb driven laser x-ray laser battle
station could be justified by the fact
that it had applications to laser
surgery well maybe but if laser surgery
is what you're about there are much
cheaper ways that do not involve
thermonuclear weapons to development
spin-off arguments are a confession that
the main thrust of the justification is
gone and you're desperately looking for
something else if if the justification
of NASA is mainly spin off
is in deep trouble it isn't but it
sometimes seems that way there are
educational aspects of human spaceflight
phd's in the United States peaked with
roughly the appropriate phase lag after
the Apollo program was was announced and
there's no question that people thought
that was something inspiring and
exciting and wanted to to work in it or
at least something connected with it but
again is it clear that this is the most
effective way of spurring interest in
science
considering how ineffective we are in
the teaching of science in the
popularization of science in the
availability of laboratories and
excellent textbooks and scholarships and
fellowships so on how much weight does
the argument based upon education
actually carry and there are some other
some other arguments some of them even
less less justifiable there's an
argument that we have to go to the moon
massively in order to strip-mine the
moon to harvest helium-3 to bring it
back to earth to power the thermo
nuclear reactors what thermo nuclear
reactors we don't have any we're
unlikely to have them on any commercial
scale for 50 years and the global
warming requires a solution to energy
problems on a shorter timescale and is
even the argument that world population
growth requires human spaceflight but
there are 250,000 more people born than
die every day on the earth and therefore
for a space flight to make a dent in
human population growth
you would have to launch 250,000 people
every day which is beyond the combined
abilities of NASA and the other
spacefaring nations for some
considerable time into the future
if I look at this list of purported
justifications the question comes down
to this can the sum of a set of
individually inadequate justifications
amount to an adequate justification if
spin off and science and an education
and a bunch of other things are none of
them by themselves a justification might
all of them together be a justification
I don't know how to do that
arcane calculus but it seems to me
that's the way the issue has to be has
to be phrased right now
NASA's focus on human space flight is
shuttle and what used to be called the
space station but there are so many of
them now better to say a space station
what are their justifications what is
space station about former vice
president Quayle justified it in the
following terms he said the United
States has to have a space station to
demonstrate that it is the world's only
superpower this like some other
statements a former vice president
Quayle are is hard to follow especially
bearing in mind that the former Soviet
Union has an operational space station
that's about ten years ahead of ours how
could it be the demonstration of
superpower status much less unique
superpower status for us to develop
something that that Russia already has
that's not a good justification if we
were convinced that we were going with
humans to the planets on sometimes like
twenty thirty years or less then of
course it's essential to understand how
humans behave in space over long periods
of time and then something like space
station would make perfect sense if
that's not what we're going to do if
that's not an urgent Nash
priority and the debate has pretty much
not been held then I don't see what the
justification is what shuttle does me
remember challengers job was to launch a
communication satellite that could just
as easily have been launched without any
humans up there we lost seven brave
Americans to do something that didn't
involve any unique abilities of human
beings almost all of what is done on
shuttle except for studying human
behavior in space could be done cheaply
and more safely in the absence of humans
the there is a new kind of solution to
these questions in which it is possible
to save a lot of money and to do
whatever it is we're gonna do up there
much quicker and that is to utilize the
space resources of other nations it's a
most interesting situation right now
where no one nation can fully justify
the very expensive missions involving
humans in space and where the
capabilities of the various nations mesh
beautifully one of the most interesting
matches is between Russia and the United
States where Russia has the MIR space
station in which cosmonauts have stayed
continuously for periods of up to a year
which is roughly the travel time one way
to Mars Russia has the energy ax
launch vehicle a Saturn 5 class launch
vehicle that can launch a hundred tons
to low Earth orbit the United States has
nothing approaching either of those two
the Russians are also desperate for hard
currency there is here a beautiful
opportunity
two for the two nations to jointly do
human spaceflight that neither nation
could effectively justify doing alone
and there is some movement in this
direction but there's a lot of
resentment and resistance in the NASA
DoD and other bureaucracies and in the
aerospace industry the president
directed in the NASA Administrator
passed on the recommendation that a
Russian team be involved in the redesign
under being undergone right now of the
US Space Station they came over were
given offices across the river in
Crystal City and a few weeks later left
in a huff they couldn't even get a
straight answer as to what was expected
of them United States policy was in
disarray on this issue as it has been
for the last many years the overall
trend though is clear US astronauts are
now planned to have a mission to Mir
Soviet cosmonauts to plan to go up on
shuttle there's a u.s. scientific
instrument on the Soviet Mars 94 Lander
there were Soviet two planetary
geologists on the Magellan mission to
Venus we're beginning to work together
but the major kind of working together
the use of the great strengths of Russia
with the great strengths of the United
States that isn't being done and it's
partly because if we buy their boosters
then some aerospace company will they
imagine lose sales of their boosters
except nobody has a Saturn 5 class
boosters of the argument is somewhat
specious if Russia in the United States
the European Space Agency in Japan maybe
a few other nations but those four
principal spacefaring nation
were to get together then the capability
would go way up the cost would after a
getting to know each other time go way
down and then I think it might be
possible to justify I'm worried that we
are not we don't have a ghost of a
chance of sending people to near-earth
asteroids or the Moon or Mars in the
next few decades if we imagine that the
United States is going to do it all by
itself for me there is a final kind of
justification for Space Flight and that
is less tangible than the sort of things
I was talking about that involves things
like like understanding from space the
perspective of the human species it's a
kind of meadow in the sky in in the
universe that is very inhospitable it
teaches us a respect for our own planet
there is something in a lot of people
not in everybody a kind of exploratory
zest and the earth is all explored there
is a need to give a kind of vision of a
hopeful future to young people who are
given the most dismal impression of the
future by what's in the media and by the
ineffectiveness of the political life
going into space provides a I think
potentially extremely important vision
of a hopeful future and that's worth
something also so I would hope that
those of you who have votes on these
issues would of course make sure that
real justification is given for proposed
expenditures especially very large
expenditures but that you will also bear
in mind
there is a large part of the National
Space Program which is clearly with a
huge margin cost effective and that
there are intangible factors that may be
difficult to quantify but that might be
nevertheless extremely important thanks
for your attention and I'd be glad to
take questions on this or anything else
on your mind
understand there's a mobile mic here it
comes anybody yes right here please say
again hi i'm connie morella and I serve
on the House Committee on Science Space
Technology from Montgomery County
Maryland but I'm curious to get your
response to the space station as it is
being watered down phase 1 2 3 are we
going to be able to come up with
something that is going to be worthwhile
should we be working more with the
Russians and the European could we
already supposedly with the European
community do you see that we're going to
be able to come up with a product or a
goal that's going to be worthwhile for
the expenditure with the watered down
versions that we're seeing Thank You
congresswoman um well this is NASA work
in progress I mean right now a nasa has
a large design team which is busily in
response to a directive from congress
redesigning and what will come out of it
nobody knows but it seems to me that a
redesign you say watering down which is
I mean it'll spend less money but maybe
it won't do things that should've been
done in the first place but to do it
without major participation by Russia
seems to me a extremely serious mistake
it's true that Japan and the Europeans
and Canada are partners but they're
partners in a very subsidiary sense that
is the United States calls the shots and
they build their own modules and attach
them we get access to their modules they
don't get access to our modules that
that has been the the u.s. approach to
international cooperation on such issues
and what the other spacefaring nations
have long been asking and what I think
is now essential is that the design of
these should be an equal partnership in
which everybody has something to say
about the long-term goals and objectives
and the
carrying it out I can't predict what the
consequence is what the results will be
of the redesign effort but it's
certainly not impossible that something
simpler and cheaper can nevertheless
accomplish all the goals that are
legitimate for for Space Station and I
would say that a whole lot of the of the
supposed scientific studies that don't
involve human physiology can be done
elsewhere without people it's the human
physiology end of things which is what
space station ought to be exclusively or
almost exclusively directed towards in
my opinion before we take another
question let me say to the Congress men
and women are here we've had the second
bells for a live quorum to be followed
by a vote and we'll have to run over and
respond to that and in just a minute
I want to leave Rob Wrigley my
administrative assistant who I know is
here Rob were you well I'll leave you
sort of to close things down in case we
don't get back in time but since we may
not get back before you have to leave I
want to thank you on behalf of everyone
here for coming and we will try to come
back and be with you some more but thank
you sir very much thank you um I'm in
favor of it I'm in favor of the nation's
business being done so please please
don't worry about me yes I represent New
York's 23rd district and I'm a senior
member the Science Committee one of the
great difficulties we have in Congress
being generalist is trying to prioritize
our scientific expenditures three years
ago the Industrial Research Institute
was asked of its members in the private
sector to prioritize five big science
megabuck projects and they came out with
the following rankings human genome was
one national aerospace was to space
station was three SDI was four and is
superconducting supercollider was dead
last five if you were asked to
prioritize those five big science
megabucks projects how would you
prioritize well the first thing I would
say is that three of them are inside
at all they use science but they're not
about science strategic defense
initiative which is just now collapsed
it's not doesn't exist anymore right
it's not the ballistic missile defense
and he should've and it doesn't even
report directly to the Secretary of
Defense it's come down in the world
that's not science that is the
application of science that has
technology to defense purposes to lump
that in the same ballpark as the human
genome project
I simply don't don't understand at all
Human Genome Project and the
superconducting supercollider and the
only two scientific items on on that
list by the way hi sherry yeah good to
see you
we're we're neighbors if if I wanted to
get prioritized I put a lot of other
things on that list I put the b2 on that
list
I'd put the C wolf attack submarine that
Department of Defense says it doesn't
need but Congress insists that it does
need for reasons of of jobs on that list
I would put a large number of weapon
systems some of which are problems about
whether they are being produced
according to specifications or on Tony
Moore on budget and some of which are
simply on unnecessary the b2 whatever
it's it's a legend function in nuclear
war that is to the authoritative
justification of the b2 by the Air Force
chief of staff a few years ago was that
its function was to destroy the Soviet
mobile ballistic missiles that had not
already been destroyed by C launched and
ballistic missiles and ICBMs that's a
completely different world we don't live
in that world anymore and and it has no
function
and yes it's spiffy to have a subsonic
bomber that is more difficult to see on
radar but considering the cost whatever
it is tens to hundreds of billions of
dollars let's strike that and likewise
there are a large number of other items
on the Department of Defense wishlist
that are not needed after the collapse
of Russia that are a dream in a nation
that has an extremely long list of
urgent needs I mean I'm thinking of of
collapsing infrastructure highways
bridges sewers aqueducts I'm thinking of
the fact the United States is 23rd in
the world and infant mortality among the
industrialized nations there are 22
other nations that save the lives of
their babies better than we do I'm
thinking about local and global
environmental issues thinking about what
our rotten education in science and lots
of other things so many American
children get I'm thinking about
homelessness and AIDS and the list as
long as my arm they all take money to
solve they are essential for national
security why national security should be
considered poured into the tiny and
parochial vessel of weaponry when so
much else is should be included I can't
understand if we persist in this
direction that won't be very much left
to defend so I think it is perfectly
legitimate to require of any scientist
or of NASA or anybody else to justify in
terms of national needs their requests
for funding especially in the
multi-billion dollar range but that
precise exercise ought to be required of
those who who are requesting that amount
of money or more for weapon systems and
the argument that that
General Dynamics Electric Boat Company
workers will be laid off in Connecticut
and therefore we have to build things we
don't need is not a good argument let's
spend some of the money saved on job
retraining and and if collapsing
infrastructure is a problem let's put
those workers let's put the workers in
the weapons laboratories national
weapons laboratories to work on solving
these kinds of problems a lot of
technological problems which need to be
solved that are essential for the
civilian economy so I know this is a
much broader answer than the question
asked for but I I guess I discover I had
it on my chest I hope in the course of
it I actually did address the question
you asked Jerry thanks so much yes part
could you identify yourself yes Jim Shaw
a former member of this glorious body
and an old friend in which I spent 26
extremely happy years can you and
unserved on the science-based Technology
Committee for many years can you suggest
some pure you didn't think much of that
list of five science projects mega
projects that you heard only two of them
you considered science projects at all
can you give us some other tidbits can
you whet our appetite for significant
science projects maybe that don't come
in the mega science category maybe
smaller projects that still have great
potential for contributing to human
wellbeing Jim I would say that that the
very fact of asking as the people Sheree
was talking about for a list of
extremely expensive projects to do in
quote science misses an essential point
and that is that a great deal the most
important science comes in ways that no
one ever could predict
comes from supporting small projects
graduate students independent research
people who don't have any practical
application in mind but just one thing
leads to another so all through the
sciences today there are problems in
which established scientific
investigators can't get the money just
to keep doing what they've been doing in
which young scientists you know recent
graduate students done extremely well
gotten their PhDs now they need some
money to to pursue their science the
money isn't available it's young people
you're on your own we don't have enough
money and as more money gets poured into
specific projects and as the National
Science Foundation is directed to spend
more money on particular programs that
reflect the national need there gets
less and less available for fundamental
research and it's a very dangerous trend
this should not be should not be
alternatives we should if we're
interested in the in the well-being of
the country and science and engineering
are important aspects of it then it's
essential to support the research of of
young scientists let me try to give just
a flavor of why this is important look
here we have a public address system
there is a television camera here are
incandescent lights give us a sense of
the technology all around us the food
was refrigerated before it came here now
where did all that electrical technology
come from suppose you were Queen
Victoria science advisor Jeff and this
is bizarre and on many levels but
imagine she came to you and said
this one Queen Victoria science advisors
not available
suppose she came to you and said you
know what I would like is a kind of box
in which there could be a moving picture
that I would be sitting at Balmoral
Castle and somehow the picture of me
would be in a box in the home of every
British citizen and that would help run
the Empire or whatever if you would say
I mean suppose that's a bizarre request
were put to you in 1850 what could you
do about this
could you have a crash program a
Manhattan Project to develop television
no way it just the science was not
available but meanwhile in that same
rough period of time there's a Scottish
physicist named James Clark Maxwell and
what he's doing is looking at
experiments on electricity and magnetism
done mainly by French scientists and he
tries to write down equations to sum up
their results and there's four equations
and he looks at them and they are
aesthetically displeasing they don't
have symmetry and he thinks they ought
to
so for aesthetic reasons only physicists
call this intuition he added another
term to make it all look nice yet that
additional term is called the
displacement current with that in you
discovered that moving electrical
charges can generate light waves and
from Maxwell's equations comes much of
modern technology now Maxwell did not
intend to do anything having to do with
the technology he was interested in how
electricity and magnetism works and just
one thing led to another now that's not
a justification for any scientist to
request money to do anything no no
there's good science and bad science you
have to make decisions but it's
important to remember
that the most vital findings often come
from somebody you never expected from
some line of work that seemed to have no
applications at all moving electrical
charges who would have figured that it
would come out of that and that's why I
would I would urge organizations that
spend money on science National Science
Foundation NASA and others to remember
that it is absolutely essential to
support many small projects especially
for young scientists any other questions
I'll be happy to take them from people
who aren't members of Congress yes one
here series cosmos suggested that we
might use nuclear-powered spacecraft to
explore the other you know the rest of
the universe how do you feel about that
today he's in in cosmos I talked about a
proposal which was called project Orion
which came out of in fact the the earth
weapons laboratories which was to use
nuclear weapons to propel against a kind
of pusher plate
but-but-but-but each nuclear explosion
being a putt a spacecraft large
spacecraft that eventually high-speed to
the outer solar system and beyond and I
gave that as one of many examples of the
kinds of technology which wouldn't be
being thought of but I stated there that
there were certain undesirable side
effects of this means of propulsion the
good one was you'd be destroying a lot
of nuclear weapons in the process but
the bad one was you'd be contaminating
nearby space with radiation and you
would not want to launch too near the
earth and so on in any case this is not
a feasible present
technology for this purpose and nuclear
weapons are being dismantled in a more
direct way both tactical and strategic
weapons in the United States and I hope
in Russia other questions if not oh yeah
a Paul Alexander with congressman sang
meister of illinois
i mean you spoke about the the crude
mission to mars do you still support
that I mean he supported it in the
eighties do you still feel that we
should do that uh my view is something
like this in the Bush administration
President Bush strongly supported human
mission tamara's it was called sei space
exploration initiative the kind of
numbers that we heard about were
hundreds of billions of dollars to send
one mission of humans to Mars and
something like a thirty year time scale
now that was widely recognized as
politically undoable nevermind
technological or other issues now you
might argue that three four or five
hundred billion dollars isn't all that
much money it's the amount stolen in the
Savings and Loan scandal and nobody
seemed to mind that very much so why not
use it here it would certainly be a
better use of it then the theft of money
by rich bankers but that's not the way
it works it turns out that three hundred
billion dollars from Mars is
unacceptable 300 billion dollars stolen
in the Savings and Loan scandal is slap
on the wrist no members of the
government as far as I know
ever been jailed for that it's too
expensive I know I'm rambling in
addition it's too far in the future
why should considerable political
capital be spent now so that 30 years
from now some other president who knows
of a different political party even
might reap the benefits if it were
possible to have a human mission to Mars
on a timescale of 10 or 15 years and a
cost of under a hundred billion dollars
which would fit well within the present
spending envelopes of NASA and the other
spacefaring nations then it's a
completely different story then it is
achievable the timescale is practical
people can work on it during a
reasonable lifetime and such a mission I
would strongly support there are some
recent studies suggesting that there
might be ways of doing that one aspect
which is you use the Russian energy ax
booster another is you use your you
provide your propellants for your return
mission to earth from Martian materials
you don't have to carry it to Mars so
under those circumstances I think I
would support it but the longer
timescale savings and loan scandal level
of expenditure missions I would not yes
space news it's a little bit of a follow
up to do with space news a little bit of
a follow up to that you had said earlier
though that before human spaceflight
should be considered the function has to
be identified what would be your
argument for the even though it would be
economically feasible for that that
human presence on Mars you remember
before I was I was asking could the sum
of a set of individually inadequate
justifications add up to an adequate one
and clearly the cheaper the overall cost
the more likely it is that
the answer to that question is yes my
seat-of-the-pants judgment and you know
if you asked me to to justify it in a
way that would convince everybody I
don't know that I could but my
seat-of-the-pants judgment is that if it
comes in under 100 million dollars and
it can be done in 10 to 15 billion years
the benefits become highly
cost-effective and by that I mean the
science even though you could do great
stuff with robots the inspirational
value for young people and others
education technological spin-off
national pride cooperation with other
nations and the building of bonds
between industrial nations all of that
put together it seems to me would be
worth and under those circumstances
same argument to Space Station though
that as the cost is decreased that those
particular benefits that people are
arguing for would become a better
argument I have more trouble with it for
Space Station although I'd be happy to
consider it for space station because
space station is not exploratory it
doesn't do any science certain on any
fundamental science it it doesn't have
the same virtues that going to Mars goes
but of course if we were going to go to
Mars
then you would have to be sure that we
could do it safely and the way to find
out what it takes to do it safely would
have to be something like Space Station
so it's a question of order but if we
made a national decision if some
president decided that this were
something historic that he or she wanted
to do then I think the role of Space
Station would fall neatly into place the
trouble is that we are trying to justify
Space Station before we have any
commitment to sending humans to the
planets and so it always seems to be in
commensurate with the objectives and
you know we always heard of shuttle as
the next step but we never heard what it
was the next step - and then we heard of
Space Station as the next step and we
never heard what it was the next step -
either in Verna von Browns vision he
knew the answer to those questions
shuttle was the step - Space Station and
Space Station was a step to Mars
but this was considered politically
infeasible to speak it its name out loud
and so we always have these truncated
assessments it's the next step don't ask
to where and I think that that issue of
what is the function of Space Station is
very much on in the minds of members of
Congress and is very much part of the
reason why there is so much skepticism
about it some of which it seems to me is
perfectly justified and some would but
some of which seems to me a little bit
unfair yes Tom Adams I'm with the
National Weather Service it seems to me
that one of the basic problems
I mean you've essentially stated it
yourself is that in justifying science
including the space shuttle or manned
space like part of the problem is is
justifying in Sullivan so philosophical
grounds and in in many ways that's the
only way we can justify any of this if
you look at this calculus of economics
in terms of trying to justify it in a
cost-benefit sort of approach you always
fall short and so a lot of it does come
down to the need to to reach out to the
universe and it is intangible and so I'm
wondering if you would agree with that
that some degree um this is
fundamentally a religious argument and
not everybody shares that particular
faith and so if Mars call to you from
childhood and if you always wanted to
visit
and if you always imagine that
human-space-flight was the obvious
culmination of the human exploratory
instinct that of course we would go
there then all of this debate seems
foolish besides the point and you know
let's get on with it but not only does
not everybody share that view I think
most people do not share that view and
if you had children who didn't have
enough to eat the idea of spending a
hundred billion much less 300 or 500
billion dollars to send some people to
Mars would seem ludicrous and that's
what I'm talking about there there's a
real point against what's the hurry they
might very well ask us Mars has been
there four and a half billion years so
it'll be there another 30 years 50 years
100 years okay for me the romantic me
the the kid who always wanted to go to
Mars you know age 7 30 50 100 years from
now doesn't answer my needs I won't be
around then very likely so I have a
personal vested interest but that should
not cloud my judgment because we're
talking about national policy and for
national policy the religious urge to go
explore the planets just doesn't carry
much water it seems to me
there are no other questions well if
that concludes our discussion today and
dr. Sagan thank you on behalf of the
Congressional Clearing House in the
future thank you for your time thanks
for some very